[Music]
I arrived here in 89 and
became the keeper of the island that I didn't
want to see anyone but for many
years my choice was to live in
direct contact with nature and
start over in a different way
what I think  you must be the life
[Music]
[Music
] yes no
I arrived here by chance without
even knowing that he resisted guts and
keeper that he was before
after two days he left it was a
stroke of luck but took the place of the
keeper president
look not  there is no one
the beauty where there is no man
welcome to my home
here the power line does not arrive therefore
or implanted with photovoltaic panels
all my current for
water rainwater because here there are no
streams water lines  they are consuming
nothing this is my Christmas tree
and these are all the objects
that man gives to the sea because
the man of the different is very generous updated
both in summer and in winter in winter
here  no one comes a year very much
the average of 30 40 books every winter
I have always said that I have many
friends as I repeat these many
months are the books that are the ones that
never betray
you even make you believe
I know by heart
I know by heart  if I know it by heart I
have obviously become a bit of a
botanist
here is the pink beach
look at what an
uncontaminated wonder and now it is not even
so pink until 94 three thousand
people arrived a day all with both mind
unconsciously they took us relaxes
whites voluntarily inside  a
bottle inside bichir
plastic bags z took 20 years to
destroy what nature has
done 10 milan
and i am no longer those de mita who
were the first years
i had actually put two gates so
that no one could enter i did not
want  communicate with anyone then
I realized that I just wanted
this beauty and I felt I
felt a lot and  goist no I
usually put it here
[Music]
it treated me very well you know in 29 years
I never got sick even I took
the winter
I never think I'll stay there as long as the
physical possibility that does not allow
the psychic one is fine for me because I am
convinced afterwards  everything that is
working on minutes to the beautiful I
am still very serene quiet I live
very well even alone I love guts
and guts it almost seems like amin
boh but I think so
and so it was born to be formed by nia
crisponi the lenk clown